who as he was boarding Air Force One on
his way to a campaign rally in Elkhart
Indiana this afternoon President Trump
predicted that his pending summit with
North Korean leader Kim jong-un would be
a quote great success
certainly the chance of his chances of
it actually happening were greatly
enhanced by the fact that North Korea
released the three remaining American
prisoners that they were holding in
Pyongyang it was just after 3 o'clock in
the morning that the three Americans
detained in North Korea touched down at
Joint Base Andrews President Trump the
vice president and first lady all on
hand to welcome them home
congratulations on being in this country
the goodwill gesture was enough to seal
the deal on a Trump Kim summit just
hours later the president tweeting the
highly anticipated meeting between Kim
jong-eun and myself will take place in
Singapore on June 12th we will both try
to make it a very special moment for
world peace
the date carries historic significance
it was on June 12 1987 that President
Ronald Reagan gave a speech and then
West Germany a speech that set the stage
for the fall of the Soviet Union mr.
Gorbachev tear down this wall White
House officials say the choice of June
12th was simply a coincidence that was
President Reagan found with Gorbachev
and glasnost
president Trump believes Kim jong-un may
want to choose a path out of isolation I
really think he wants to do something I
think he did this because I really think
he wants to do something and bring that
country into the real world in an effort
to keep Kim moving toward the bargaining
table president Trump has dropped the
harsh rhetoric of little Rocketman and
brutal dictator going so far this
morning is to praise Kim for releasing
the detainees
was excellent to these three incredible
people the compliment brought sharp
criticism from the Senate Minority
Leader the exultation by the president
and others of the greatness of North
Korea doing this evades me we can't be
fooled into giving the North Korean
regime credit for returning Americans
that never should have been detained in
the first place
in response to Schumer the House speaker
today said give the president a break he
is preparing for a summit with a leader
of North Korea to focus on
denuclearization so I think we all
should give the president some leeway on
preparing for this summit and to do and
by the way it was a good-faith gesture
while President Trump liked the idea of
a summit at peace house in the DMZ where
Kim and South Korea's president recently
met Singapore was always the first
choice of his aides close enough for Kim
to get to with the limited fleet of
aircraft that is neutral territory for
North and South Korea fully equipped to
host a major summit in a city renowned
for excellent security just about two
weeks before this summit Singapore hosts
an international security conference
where delegates come from all over the
Indo Pacific including the United States
to talk about mutual security needs so I
think it makes a lot of sense it's an
ideal location and president Trump also
had his eye on domestic issues today
specifically the farm bill in a White
House meeting today with the Agriculture
Secretary sonny Perdue Senator Pat
Roberts of Kansas and Congressman Mike
Conaway the president said that he
expects when the language of the bill is
drafted that it will include measures
that would require work for people who
are on food stamps while the president
said he expects that to be in the
legislation he stopped short of issuing
what was expected to be a veto threat if
they balked at doing that right hey John
there's a story in The New York Times
headlined Homeland Security Secretary
close was close to resigning after Trump
paraded her and it goes on to talk about
an inch
then what do we know about that what we
do know is that in the cabinet meeting
yesterday I have confirmed this through
sources kirsten nielsen felt like she
was singled out and berated by the
president over what he saw as a lack of
border security the New York Times
report says that she was close to
resigning over it and that she had
drafted a letter of resignation what we
are hearing from sources at DHS is that
a tweet will be coming soon that would
deny the existence of a resignation
letter the meet it may be that she was
saying something to the effect of well
if I'm not doing a good job maybe I
shouldn't be in this job but as far as
drafting a formal resignation letter
that appears to not be the case at least
according to sources that we have heard
from tonight Brett okay we'll follow
that gen Robert slob in the North claw
and John thanks